yeah thank you have a great time and
thanks for making it so much fun
yeah thank you as well and good luck on
wednesday with england all right here we
go the blitz has
started it has started magnus carson
with the white pieces he opens with the
king's pawn we're going to see the
spanish opening
he's putting pressure on the black
knight retreating his bishop there
this is all very standard stuff white
castling he'll defend his central pawn
now
white central pawn under attack black's
gonna hurry to get his king to safety
and uh what will we see from magnus
carson okay he pushes a pawn in the
center just one square this is again
very normal both sides have an enormous
amount of experience in this exact
position
they've played it several times before
very tense with all pieces and pawns on
the board
white has slightly more control of the
center especially with his pawns
black finally castling his king and
magnus he initiates some
activity some threats on this left flank
trying to undermine
one of the black pawns that has advanced
the furthest so ding
will most likely either move that pawn
or protect it
ding has a lot of experience from the
black side
magnus has experience from the white and
black side so maybe magnus with a slight
edge in terms of
general understanding and just general
experience in these positions
lots of maneuvers not too much changing
yet both pieces both sides are putting
their pieces getting ready
for the action that's about to happen
yeah the players are playing incredibly
quickly i mean this is a
good kind of news for a magnus and ding
because they're able to
accumulate an extra time in preparation
for
the middle game and uh okay so
ding tucking the bishop back and uh the
bishop might even maneuver itself to
another diagonal
yep the bishop tends to be in the way
sometimes where it did stand so black
just retracing that as a protector of
the black king
magnus just again taking squares taking
territory staying flexible
um that's the key in blitz quite often
you stay flexible it's actually easier
and quicker
if you just react to what your opponent
does it takes a lot of time investment
to be creative and that's what ding's
trying to do now maybe push pawn forward
in the middle first he brings his rook
to the side
he's just trying to look for ideas to
kind of put magnus off balance right now
i expect him
magnus just again not commit too much
bring one of his white knights
back maybe remaneuver one of those white
knights yeah i'm expecting that as well
it's the main move okay but
uh magnus instead he adopts one of his
favorite strategies and it's very
effective one actually
which is expanding as much as possible
on the left um he's he's been very very
effective there and
it's a kind of newish idea hasn't been
played before
but certainly we've seen it in operation
before from magnus
yep so in this type in this exact
position a rare move from magnus but in
general
a very well-known plan from him and
black's knight stepping back
some viewers might wonder why is that
knight retreating to what looks like a
passive square actually
that black knight didn't have a future
where it did stand it wasn't attacking
anything couldn't jump forward to
black's re-routing his knight towards
the kingside in front of the black king
as a potential defender
magnus occupying the center with his
pawns now both sides being very
classical very
logical play so far magnus brings his
knight that way i thought the white
knight maybe would step back towards his
king
traditionally that's a very safe plan
but no magnus thinks there's more of a
future for his knight on the left side
of the board
white tends to have a tiny advantage in
these types of positions because
he has two pawns in the middle black
only has one and white can choose any
time when to make a trade or when to
advance
but ding fighting for the open line yeah
talking about making a trade well dings
offered
a trade of rooks just now so okay so if
i were white i would say no
and i do like magnus's move just like
stepping the bishop forward
and uh getting ready maybe to step
forward with the queen and connect the
rooks
yep so magnus allowing that trade but
it's on his terms white's queen will
most likely go across there
and now the white queen occupies an open
line black's queen
the queen and bishop are lined up on a
diagonal maybe
just maybe one day that bishop will
sacrifice
itself over on the right and well then
we will have absolute carnage yep so
there was a potential sacrifice in the
air on the h3 square so the pawn in
front of the white king right now but
the white king
is defending that pawn is keeping all of
the pawns around it defended
that was pretty much a pretty much
forced move there uh
by magnus otherwise he would have come
under heavy fire yeah so the black
knight is now trying to get into the
game
magnus shifting his bishop over to the
king yep as i was going to say
just uh ding should just put one of his
knights onto a dream
f4 square and magnus really takes that
potential attack very very seriously and
that's why he
drops his light square bishop back to
defend against
any potential sacrifices on those light
squares around the king
yep so shaky from magnus but efficient
so far defending everything and asking
ding what are you going to do next
so black didn't have any sacrifices no
breakthrough on the white king position
so black just pushes a pawn yeah and
well still the advantage for magnus lies
on the right
uh sorry on the left uh he's got
domination there he controls the open
line
and he also has the potential just to
start
throwing some pieces forward there so i
would be tempted to
maybe clarify the situation in the
center and then
come forward so yep white's queen could
jump into the black
well it's the heart of the black
position but it's not clear what next
she wouldn't be threatening anything
yeah i would hesitate to do that i would
think
the white queen actually might get hit
might get kicked around there wouldn't
be too much harmony if the queen's out
on her own not being supported by pieces
so
maybe in the air but not right now i
think for magnus carlsen
one thing i would definitely do is i
would clarify in the center
you wouldn't yeah what would it you
david uh i was going to say no but
magnus agrees with you okay um he did
trade a set of pawns there so actually
the pawn structure is completely
symmetrical
it's all about peace play now no
imbalances in terms of the pawns
like that with his bishop just
controlling some squares yeah the more i
think about about it the more i like it
actually
um this decision because now white does
have squares does have access into the
position
that night was too strong had to be
traded off and
uh now bishop takes bishop looks
looks like the most not oh but look at
that uh
magnus with a different idea in mind he
plays pawn takes bishop
wow yeah very surprising because white
has doubled his own pawns voluntarily
on the sea line white has these two
double pawns they might be very strong
controlling some squares but they might
also be very weak
later in the game big decision there
committal decision from magnus
clock situation roughly balanced so far
both sides just over three minutes
but either way that last move has caused
ding luren to think
and that's one good thing in blitz
surprise your opponent not just in the
opening in the middle game
um if you can do that as well even in
the end game if you can surprise them
they lose a bit of time on the clock and
the momentum
could change so yeah i didn't expect
that one either but
it does look with hindsight as if uh it
has
caused ding lauren a bit of confusion
and he's got to readjust
he's got to re-adapt the black knights
they look nice and pretty but actually
they're kind of sat defending each other
not really going anywhere
yeah the more i look at this more i
think actually it's not easy for black
he's still still fine like no threats
um no real kind of
issues to worry about apart from the
fact that the black knights don't have
much of a future
yet so ding needs to correct that
yeah i mean is there's no immediate
threat right now from white so
okay i mean how pressing is it to uh
just move one of the knights maybe could
you just perhaps uh take
okay yup this was the move i was
expecting just to defend all the pawns
black central pawn was a bit tender
only defended by one night so i'm doing
taking control of some dark squares as
soon as he's parted with his dark square
bishop
i expect to see white's rook maybe reach
an open line now
maybe it's time for one of those queen
no i mean i like this move
um the rook now gets involved in the
game you know magnus likes to use every
single piece
so um okay now it's time for your knight
to relocate itself or some trades to
happen
yeah it's not easy to see where those
black knights go that's the issue like
they will get hit later on and ding
loren he doesn't find a way to improve
his pieces too much so he thinks okay
the black king maybe needs to be the
most um urgent one that can improve and
now white's rook
looking fantastic it is that looking
absolutely amazing i mean
now there's going to be some heavy
pressure against that backward pawn and
this is why ding not necessarily feeling
comfortable
in his position decides just to activate
and just
create chaos yeah he shook his head
there he realizes that
there was nothing else to do maybe there
were better moves but the momentum was
against him the tide was turning
and when the tide turns often you need
to
play this type of move force your
opponent to think suddenly
shock them with these pawn pushers give
them a question to answer
white now has to deal with his central
pawn it does feel very loose for black
so objectively if magnus had a lot of
time
it should be good for white that's
confirmed by the evaluation bar but
i do like it because um that last move
forces magnus now to make a huge
decision
what would you do ivanka would you trade
some pieces trade a set of pawns i would
trade a set of pawns
um and then i was actually thinking of
uh
centralizing my queen okay the white
queen yeah
getting getting bringing across the
board on the first row
and you know maybe have with you some
ideas of uh
attack oh i'm such a once i've got a
such a one-track mind on this kind of
positions
but often that's effective in blitz
chess yeah and magnus
he can't really afford this long i think
this is actually why i mentioned i like
ding's move because it does initiate
this
real tension and a big decision for
magnus but magnus has spent half his
time on this
one move he had a huge time advantage
actually and that's all gone now he's
down on the clock just over a minute
takes night bishop takes knight okay
okay so giving up the bishop pair but
getting rid of a potentially
dangerous black knight okay so the most
natural move is actually just plain
knight takes bishop
knight takes bishop and say yes you got
rid of one night great another one is
coming
okay so black that's the most active
plan to
approve the black knight but you would
have to work out what happened because
black would have given up a central pawn
in that case
black decides to trade but recapture
with his pawn
so that pawn no longer under fire but
you're not you're not
approving ivanka no because i do feel
that when it comes to
rapid chess i mean you have to speed up
the momentum and again
focus not on playing the most perfect
move you should be playing the most
practical moves and i feel like going
forward
generating activity with your pieces is
the most
important thing there is i mean just
look at the consequence of that porn
capture because suddenly look look at
white's knight
in the center dream piece and you can
see ding shaking his head he doesn't
like his position at all
and uh oh look pressure on those light
squares i mean
what you know magnus is really turning
the corkscrew
screw here you know so many problems for
ding along those light squares
yeah white's move there just shifting
the queen across one square
it looks nice and innocent looks naive
but the queen again sliding across one
square
that queen just can't decide where it
wants to be but note how the queen's
attacking something on every turn that
white queen now attacking a black pawn
across a diagonal and black has one
undefended pawn in his camp
the white queen going after it very
nasty stuff
magnus really amping up the pressure and
how can black defend that pawn it's not
easy if black continues pushing pawns in
front of the black king the black king
is going to become a huge target
and okay the bishop's stepping back
what's stopping white from taking that
point
nothing nothing david okay he takes
another pawn first
that doesn't matter it doesn't change
the uh scheme of things
he knows he's in trouble he's shaking
his head there white about to unleash
his queen
the queen is about to join the party
white's queen can jump out and take a
pawn and then
the black king is going to be in huge
trouble yeah
yeah look how safe white king is with
three pawns around it black's king is
about to
really become open and black queen the
black queen meanwhile
helpless unable to join the party
herself
and we are under that minute on the
clock which means uh always a lot of fun
in the blitz games
and uh unfortunately it is ding that is
suffering because he just
has uh over 30 seconds on the clock and
all these queen moves relentless i mean
he's just
torturing uh ding along the back row you
know
i love it that queen move because now
the big threat is actually to
maybe potentially well push the pawn
forward
at the right time yeah white lining up
the queen with the black king that is a
key concept here
and it's just all these shuffles with
the queen queen to long range pieces as
well as
dynamic attackers and okay ding now
desperation look at the evaluation bar
plus 8.8
the black rook is going to try and act
as maybe a defender of the black king
but
brooks aren't great defenders they're
not great blockaders as you mentioned
white pawn can step up
and that would be a discover check where
it's queen hitting the black king that
looks deadly
yeah i'd also be tempted to jump in with
my night i miss
i'm spoiled for sure centralize the
white queen that's it yeah magnus's
style all over
and okay black trying to hold things
together with the black queen but the
black queen looks overworked
she's protecting a knight she's
protecting a bishop it feels like just
one move will break
the defenses now if magnus is accurate
and
he jumps in with the knight and ding
retreats the night there's nothing for
it and uh what
a commanding performance and uh wow
checkmate is coming
on the board and is there any way
there's no way to defend against it no
ding resigns the white queen was about
to
jump in across the diagonal supported by
the white bishop to trap the black king